once a standard way of settling
disagreements duels were not all pistols
at dawn this is a short history of
unusual duels there is one unusual door
above all others the dual monsieur
versus monsieur famous dancer mama zell
dear feets was lover of one mistress to
the other it simply wouldn't do the
weapons were to be blunderbusses being
men of elevated minds they decided they
should have an elevated fight a huge
crowd gathered to watch as degrom pray
the peak and their seconds ascended to
2,000 feet they were to duel in hot-air
balloons
about 80 yards apart de Peixe fired
first
he missed the ground prey aimed and took
his shot de peak and his second were
both dashed to pieces across the
rooftops of Paris the victor Monsieur de
Grand Prix who floated to safety some 20
miles away this has been a short history
of unusual duels no of other unusual
duels let us know in the comments